so in this example we want to hit an
apple that's hanging from a tree with
the projectile and the main point of the
problem is to figure out at what angle
to the ground should we aim our
projectile when we fire it off in order
to hit the apple and in this example
we're assuming that the apple drops from
the tree at the same instant that we
fire the projectile so in this drawing
let's just put some dimensions in here
we'll assume that the apple starts out
at a height H above the ground that the
horizontal distance for the from where
the projectile starts to the Apple is a
distance D that the projectile starts at
a distance s above the ground and that
we fire the projectile off with an
initial velocity V not at an angle theta
sorry theta naught with respect to the
horizontal okay and let's define our
origin to be right here on the ground
directly below where the projectile
begins we need to define our coordinate
system so the I hat direction will be
horizontally to the right and the J hat
direction will be vertically upwards
okay with an origin at this point so the
question that we have is what should our
angle theta naught be in order to hit
the Apple which starts falling from the
tree at the same instant that we fire
our projectile and we want to hit the
Apple before it hits the ground okay so
to work this out we need to consider the
kinematics of two separate objects our
projectile and the apple so let's begin
with the Apple so for our Apple
the Apple drops vertically straight
downward so it's horizontal position
throughout its motion is just unchanged
so the x-coordinate of the Apple as a
function of time is just D it's it's a
constant its y-coordinate it starts out
at a height H and then it drops due to
the acceleration of gravity and so
that's given by minus one-half G T
squared so minus because it's falling in
the minus J hat direction now for our
projectile let's call it a bullet for
our bullet the x-coordinate of the
bullet it starts out at the origin at x
equals zero and its initial motion it
has an initial velocity V naught in this
direction the horizontal component of
that is V naught times the cosine of
theta naught and so it's displacement at
time T is V naught T times the cosine of
theta naught and there's no horizontal
acceleration so that completes our our x
coordinate as a function of time for our
y coordinate we start out at a height s
above the ground there's the change in
the y-coordinate due to the initial
velocity which has component V naught
sine theta naught so that's plus V
naught T sine theta naught and there's
also a vertical acceleration due to
gravity which gives us minus 1/2 g t
squared okay so that's our kinematics of
the Apple and the bullet now for there
to be a hit at time T equals capital T
the coordinates of the Apple and the
bullet have to be the same at that
collision time so
for a hit at t equals big t we require
that the x-coordinate of the bullet at
time Big T is the same as the
x-coordinate of the Apple and likewise
that the y-coordinate of the bullet is
equal to the y-coordinate of the Apple
okay so let's look at each of these in
turn for our x-coordinate the
x-coordinate of the bullet is V naught
capital t times the cosine of theta
naught and that has to be equal to the
x-coordinate of the apple which is just
d so notice that i can solve this for
the time of the collision capital t and
that's just d minus V naught times the
cosine of theta dot now for our y
coordinate the y-coordinate of the
bullet is s plus V naught capital T
times the sine of theta naught minus 1/2
g t squared and that's equal to the
y-coordinate of the Apple which is H
minus one-half GT squared
all right now I can rearrange that
notice that I have a minus 1/2 GT
squared on both sides so those cancel
out I can rearrange that to write V
naught times capital T times the sine of
theta naught is equal to H minus s so
that the sine of theta naught is equal
to H minus s over V naught capital T but
remember we solved for capital T here so
I can substitute that in so that gives
me H minus s over V naught times 1 over
T which is V naught cosine theta naught
over D and so I can rewrite that as H
minus s over D times the cosine of theta
naught so rewriting that I have on the
left hand side sine of theta naught over
cosine of theta naught is equal to H
minus s over D and notice on the left
hand side sine over cosine is just
tangent so this is just the tangent of
theta naught now think about what that
means if I draw a right triangle where
this is Theta naught and this is H minus
s and this is D and so this is the same
geometry we have here if we do the
triangle like this so theta naught is
just the angle to the location of the
Apple just before it drops so what this
calculation tells us is that the correct
thing to do if we want to hit the Apple
if we know the Apple is going to drop at
the same instant that we fire then we
should aim at the location that the
Apple is at that instant
okay we shouldn't try and lead the Apple
and fire below it or fire above it we
should aim directly at the Apple and
what the kinematics tells us is that
both the bullet and the Apple fall
vertically down at the same rate and so
that will give us a collision now
it's worth thinking about two different
cases which I'm not going to solve for
you here the first is what if the Apple
didn't drop suppose the Apple just
stayed in the tree and I fired okay if I
aim directly at the Apple on the Apple
didn't drop that I would miss the Apple
because the bullet would drop as it went
across this distance D now of course if
the Apple were big enough or if the
bullet were flying fast enough if V
naught was fast enough then it might be
that the amount of the bullet dropped
wouldn't be bigger than the thickness of
the Apple so I might still graze the
Apple but I wouldn't hit the Apple dead
center so if I knew that the Apple
wasn't going to drop and I wanted to hit
a dead center I would have to choose
some different angle theta naught we can
sort of see intuitively that that angle
would have to be a little bit steeper so
that the bullet would drop and then hit
the Apple and so the way we would solve
that is in our original kinematic
equations for the for the motion of the
Apple X would still be a constant d but
if the Apple wasn't dropping then Y if
the Apple would also be a constant we
wouldn't have the second term we would
just have y equals H and then I would
have to solve for a collision the other
case to think about that I'd like you to
think about is what if the Apple begins
dropping for a short interval before we
fired so that at the time that we fire
our projectile the Apple is already
dropping well that's equivalent to
saying that at time equals zero when I
fire that the Apple has some initial
velocity whatever velocity it's picked
up by dropping and whatever interval is
dropping before so now my kinematics for
my Apple in the vertical direction I
would have an additional term here a
minus V naught T where V naught is that
initial velocity okay and that's a
different V naught I should have used a
different symbol it's a different V
naught in the V naught of the bullet
there would be an initial velocity
falling velocity of the Apple that I'd
have to consider so the particular
details of what's happening with the
Apple change the kinematics and it's
worth thinking about how that would
change your answer